we now know that dozens of people have
been rescued in Orlando and Adriana Diaz
is in that neighborhood Adriana Jeff
we're in the neighborhood of Orolo Vista
we're just west of downtown where
rescues are currently underway we just
saw a truckload of people being taken
out they look so relieved they were
waving and thanking the rescuers the
National Guard into your service Orange
County Fire and Rescue they brought
their boats to help in the relief effort
there was flooding here that was
waist-deep in at least two dozen homes
we actually saw a dog being rescued that
looked very relieved in all at least 100
people have been evacuated from here
including kids now not too far away
thirty people were evacuated from a
building after a 30-foot sinkhole opened
up people from another building were
also taken out and these folks have been
taken to a local because the conditions
are just too intense right now later on
once things calm down they'll be
relocated to a shelter now with these
types of winds of course the Orlando
Airport is closed but the airport has
been allowing military cargo planes full
of medical personnel to land over the
past few days now these are doctors
nurses pharmacists even men who've been
brought into the state of Florida to be
positioned to help in the relief effort
now locally there are 500 emergency
responders who are standing by they're
in the county's Convention Center
they're ready to go out as they're
needed Jeff Adriana thank you very much